hey guys welcome back to brand-new View
Rebecca I'm Monster Hunter world again
and today we're just gonna be showing
off some of the gameplay that the
Monster Hunter developer showed off
couple of the Japanese guys basically
had a hunt with them she lost some of
the gameplay talked about it gave her
thoughts stuff like that so I thought
I'd look through the gameplay break it
down a bit too we can think of and see
we can come off with just a little bit
before he releases so as always like the
V if you do enjoy the discography new I
covered the solo guides a Monster Hunter
world the event quest every week so that
everyone knows what to beat what to do
and want to get caught up with and tips
and tricks to make everyone a better
Monster Hunter player as well as
covering leaks and news about the game
so let's get started but going over the
main beginning gist of this the quest is
going to be called he taketh with his
eyes the main objective is to slay the
behemoth the conditions are HR 16 or
higher so most hunters will be able to
do this and the time limit is reduced it
is not a 50-minute quest it is 35
minutes so as I said gameplay of
behemoth was just released and it seems
to be a pretty crazy flight from the
gameplay it seems that his tail is
severable and has a ton of crazy high
damaging moves as everyone knows you're
gonna be in the other recess for this
fight and seems to follow a similar path
like Norco granted during the fight in
terms of the areas that you fight him in
he also seems to has two phases one in
normal and then one in the red skin tone
to it this could just be speculation but
it seems like in this phase this is
where all the high damaging meteor
attacks come from Cal seems to have a
standard meteor strike which comes in
the regular phase and an AoE fire blast
which could possibly come in the regular
face and both I have no clue it could
just be a normal move or it could be a
phase specific move he also has this
crazy body skeleton which everyone has
always seen and he seems to be one of
the biggest monsters and monster on the
world that does not require a whole new
area which is pretty interesting next up
was this huge blast attack and from what
I can gather it does crazy amounts of
damage has a huge distance in terms of
range and is very bad if you're near him
whatsoever so definitely try to stay
away as far as possible but we'll get
into a little bit more tips on that move
later in the video you know it also
seems that he can also be sleep - which
as shown in the stream the hunters
managed to basically sleep him and you
can get a quick shot of what seems like
you can break both of behemoth horns off
his head which is really nice as well
more breakable parts for you to hit and
there also seems to be this weird laser
attaching itself to the monster I'm not
entirely sure if that's a new thing or
judging from one of the tips will also
talk about later in the video I do
believe that's what it is or maybe be
something that already exists you guys
will have to let
Meno on your thoughts on it behemoth
also seems to have a tail sweep although
it didn't really do much damage as the
hunters managed to cut off his tail
early in the fight so we didn't really
see the full effect of it and behemoth
also has another blast attack that
explodes in multiple times in a straight
line whatever he chooses and it was hard
to tell but it seems like his weak spots
are so far his head tail and maybe his
legs or underbelly no confirmation on
the last two though next clip was the
hunters successfully killing behemoth by
either smacking her or let her injure
itself but it was still cool to see it
being slain and they had some of the
tips from the team which I told you
about in the earlier part of this video
and some of their tips as recommended
are a term called anemone which
basically means it's like aggro or
attention and you want to get the most
from attacking his head which seems to
be the most amount of aggro you can
receive and it could possibly be that
red laser that we saw earlier that is
gonna be a grow or anemone whatever you
want to call it and it seems to be of
course tracking whoever draws the most
anemone will basically have behemoths on
him the most the elliptic meteor also
has a supergiant range which I talked
about before you can't run away from it
and if you're within the impact zone it
is an instant feint regardless of your
health and the only way to stop the move
is if you baha'i if you hide behind one
of the following meteors which you'll
see scattered throughout the gameplay on
the ground so simply just hide behind
one of those hopefully not with in the
direction of the meteor and you should
live the damage if you're in a teamfight
though make sure someone has guard up or
any type of guard ability whatever
weapon they happen to use and have them
draw the most amount of the attention
from behemoth and then let the other
players focus on him while he's
distracted wide range health boost and
guts according to them are super
recommended skills while the recommended
weapons are water elemental weapons or
paralysis and possibly having an
augmentation for health regen one of the
huge reasons they wanted to have wide
range as a skill because if your
teammate is trying to guard behind this
attacks he can't heal while he's getting
attacked so you have to have your one
teammate heal you while you guard up or
anything like that which is a super
recommended skill and then once defeated
on screen you'll see the collaboration
armor as I said is on screen and I'm
assuming even the moogle armor which
could possibly be your palico just just
judging from the photo either way the
armor looks sweet and the insect wave as
well just looks absolutely amazing so
yeah let me know what you guys thought
about the gameplay if you happen to
watch the stream and I missed something
tell me in the comments below or just
judging from the gameplay anything that
you picked out or anything like that I'd
love to
thoughts in the comments below as always
like the V if you do enjoy subscriber
for new I cover the solo gods of every
monster just about every monster monster
hundred world I will definitely be
covering a guide on behemoth I've so
much to talk about this monster when he
releases he just looks so cool with the
merchant moves and the different ways
that you can guard these moves and stuff
like that so I cannot wait to talk about
this guy once I get my hands on him
I also cover tips and tricks news and
leaks all that stuff about monster
hunter world so if you want to get
up-to-date on monster hunter world with
leaks or news or you just want to become
a better Monster Hunter player and
deftly consider subscribing and staying
with the channel my two most recent
videos would be on the screen if you
guys want to check that out with that
guys would have a great yesterday thank
for watching the video and peace out
guys thanks for watching